build up a picture of what's going on
this evening we know from what police
have told us that they have found a body
let's just have a look at some of the
images that we've got now of some police
activity on the housing estate about
half a mile away from amber Pete's
family home in Mansfield this clearly
shows a police tent a white tent white
and blue tent along what looks like a
lane and the grass verge and a hedgerow
clearly near some houses this is police
activity that's happening right now in
Mansfield it's clearly hot speculate but
it's obviously major police activity in
an area where they've been searching for
13 year old amber for the last three
days it will be a significant scene of
forensic investigation for not even sure
police and this area has we understand
being sealed off for the last at least
an hour possibly more whilst forensic
officers continue investigations most
likely inside that tent whilst police
officers we can see in some of the
pictures stand guard outside now clearly
the search for amber has now ended and
in his entering stage of what happened
to her
how did that body become situated there
and what forensic ly can be gleaned from
that crime scene that we may give them
an idea of what's happened to the 30
year old